plus d'une centaine doivent se
rassembler au musée saint roch pour
cette rétrospective d'un artiste à
l'indéniable talent une vision idéaliste
et humaniste du monde non exempte d'un
certain pessimisme
l'artiste a connu des drames personnels
la nostalgie de son pays
et tout ceci se reflète dans un style
qu'il a ciselé à la perfection
on peut effectivement parler
d'abstraction pour son travail néanmoins
donne des titres ses tableaux il ya des
figures qui apparaissent et des
histoires effectivement qui sont
inhérentes à ces tableaux donc c'est un
artiste de la non-figuration difficile à
classer placé néanmoins c'est un artiste
qui qui fait ressortir une très grande
poésie dans cet amour
c'est en 1953 que le jeune abdallah
arrive en france il travaille sans
relâche la peinture mais aussi à la
gravure et à la réalisation de livres
d'artistes professeur à l'école
nationale des beaux-arts de paris toute
son évolution picturale est liée aux
grands événements du groupe
en 90 la guerre en irak va remettre une
grande déception à l'artiste la
situation des conflits en algérie
également donc peut-être le
positionnement d'un artiste qui se
questionnent qui s'interroge
effectivement sur son rôle qui peut être
est touché par une certaine forme de
désespoir
ces tableaux souvent de grands formats
aux lumière contrastée et aux couleurs
éclatantes révèle au spectateur attentif
des silhouettes trace de présence
d'êtres chers ou symbole d'une
philosophie de l'existence sa marque de
fabrique